[Music]  [Applause]  we went over the plan five times I got  the packaged at night  we need a pickup hang on  [Music]  so this is the top team the road clones  on the run from the Empire huh hello how  juicy  the Empire is growing stronger we should  be doing more  you want to really be free then pull off  this Heist and you can have a future  rumors are more and more clones have  been questioning the order than their  traitors like the Jedi  you all gave up everything because of me  we made the right choice Omega but there  are others out there who need our help  what sort of treachery is this stay back  [Music]  we are not the enemy the Empire seeks to  establish peace and Order throughout the  Galaxy peace  peace was never an option  we're soldiers we do what needs to be  done you know it makes us different we  make our own choices  what do you need Rex any chance I could  use you for a mission  parents the bad badge new season  streaming January 4th only on Disney  Plus